a two-month cease-fire in yemen between
houthi rebels and the saudi-led
coalition is the most significant
breakthrough in years
some flights from sana airport are
allowed under the deal and fuel imports
can reach houthi held areas
a halt to the fighting coupled with the
entry of full ships and the easing of
restrictions on the movement of people
and goods in out and within the country
will contribute to building trust
and creating a conducive environment to
resume negotiations for a peaceful
settlement of the conflict
the truth coincides with the start of
the holy month of ramadan
it's the most important step in years
towards ending a conflict that's killed
tens of thousands of people and pushed
millions into hunger i think it's just
strategic exhaustion the houthis for a
long time had felt that it was just an
inevitable uh uh their success was
inevitable but they had a huge setback
in mara which had been uh besieged for
you know over a year so i think that
both sides kind of realized you know
this war is not going the way we want to
maybe we're going to have to settle for
half a loaf
attacks between houthis and the
coalition escalated recently when a
saudi oil facility was hit by houthis
last week
riyadh struck back
some believe the war has become
unwinnable
the last coordinated ceasefire was in
2016. other peace agreements have led to
failure
[Applause]
it's a step forward but we don't know
you know if
this fire will hold um time will tell
but
in any case it um step in in the right
direction and i must say it took
seven
long years for this truth to be
agreed on it's extraordinary
a conflict widely seen as a proxy war
between saudi arabia and iran has
devastated yemen
the un's special envoy says the
two-month truce could be extended if
both parties agree
a sign of hope after years of fighting
katie lopez
al jazeera